hello everyone it's seven o'clock this
is Sky News breakfast it's now a week
since Nicola bully disappeared seemingly
Without a Trace while walking her dog in
Lancashire this morning we'll bring you
her family's emotional appeal that
somebody somewhere must know something
and we'll have the latest from Michael's
on wire where that search continues
plus rail workers on strike again will
hear from the head of the group
representing the train operators and
later laborers Stephen kennick it's
Friday the 3rd of February
her children need her a family's plea
for answers as the search for missing
mum Nicola bully reaches its second week
somebody must know something somebody
must know
somebody people don't just vanish Into
Thin Air
I'll have the latest on the police
investigation from where Nicola went
missing here in Saint Michael's on wire
more disruption for rail passengers as
train drivers strike again
the Pentagon tracks a spy balloon
believed to be Chinese spotted in U.S
airspace
cancer cases forecast to rise by a third
by 2040.
keeping the lights on the National Grid
tells Sky News its new energy saving
scheme could become the norm
his sport grandpotters Chelsea face
Fulham tonight after a record-breaking
transfer window
in the weather generally mild and mainly
fine in the South but the north can
expect more wind and rain and
[Music]
[Applause]
then
the rush to buy tickets as Beyonce
announces her first new tour in nearly
seven years
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
to you it's now a week since Nicola
bully went missing while walking her dog
in the Lancashire Village of Saint
Michael's on wire and her disappearance
remains a mystery there were some 25
minutes between Nicola's last sighting
and her phone and dog being found on a
bench in that time she vanished her
family has told Sky News that somebody
must know something and say they're
living in a nightmare Nicholas Sister
Louise and father Ernie were speaking to
Skies imsaband Rasheed
somebody must know something somebody
must know
somebody people don't just vanish Into
Thin Air there's got to be somebody that
knows something and all we are asking no
matter how small or big if there's
anything that you can remember that just
doesn't seem right then please reach out
to the police please just get in touch
and
get my sister back
what are you missing now oh don't
is
see it's old
we're such a
a close-knitive family we are we are
closely at the family sorry we do
anything for any one of us and the
children would do the same for us
so
yeah just
I hope she comes home
so this is what we know about Nicola
Bully's last movements she went missing
early last Friday morning after driving
10 minutes from her home in Inskip to
the nearby Village of Saint Michael's on
wire
she dropped her children off at school
before heading down garstang road with
her dog Willow there she began her walk
around the river at around 8 43 A.M
about 8 50 she was seen in the lower
field it was at around this time that a
woman wearing a red coat was also seen
and police asked her to come forward as
a potential eyewitness and she has now
been spoken to
Nicholas sent an email to her boss at 8
53 am
at 901 she logged on to a team's call
and about nine minutes later a witness
who knows Nicola saw her in the upper
field still with her dog Willow
at 9 30 the team's call ended but Nicola
stayed logged on
Nicholas mobile phone and Willow were
found at a bench by the river by another
dog walker at about 9 35.
well Sky's Frozen Ward is there in St
Michael's on wire for us this morning so
Fraser incredibly distressing for for
the family waiting for news but in the
meantime what is the latest on the
police investigation
yeah good morning well it's in just a
little over two hours time it will be
exactly one week since Nicola went
missing the police say that they still
don't believe there was a third party
involved that they still don't believe
uh that uh that there was any other
involvement in her disappearance and
they are keeping an open mind having
said that their investigations will
continue they have Nicholas mobile phone
which was left logged on to a team's
call which was discovered some 20
minutes or so after the last positive
sighting of Nicholas so they will be
searching that for any potential
forensic evidence they'll continue their
searches along the Riverbanks and in the
river as well this is a search that's
involved not just Lancashire police but
the local mountain rescue teams fire and
rescue Service as well as they try and
comb the Riverbanks comb the river
itself to try and find any Trace at all
of Nicola and with it being one week on
we humans well our work and social lives
make us creatures of habit and so it's
likely that people who are in the area
in the next the vowels Also may well
have been in this area last Friday as
well so the police as well as many
concerned members of the community here
and many of Nicholas family friends and
so on will be out as well this morning
they'll be giving out leaflets they'll
be talking to people in the area hoping
that they may have seen something uh
last week a week ago today that could
provide the vital clue to finding uh
Nicola alive the family say they are
living a nightmare at the moment and
have been for a week now it was
heartbreaking to see wasn't it Nicholas
sister and her father putting out that
emotional appeal speaking to our
correspondent intermember Sheed
yesterday they are desperate for any
piece of information as are the police
they say they continue to keep an open
mind the searches here will continue
today but still one week on The
Disappearance of Nicola bully remains a
mystery
Fraser thanks very much indeed
now large areas of the country will be
left without any rail Services again
today as train drivers and rail workers
strike for the second time in a week
members of asleff and the rail Maritime
and transport Union are rmt are walking
out on a long-running dispute over pay
and conditions
well Sky's Melania vesalinovich is at
the London Houston for us this morning
simulator another day of disruption for
passengers but there is an offer on the
table for the rmt at the moment isn't
there so is it possible that a
resolution is is getting closer
foreign
hard to say Anna they've been
negotiating for months and what we've
heard from union leaders so far this
time as love assistant Secretary General
is that the dispute had gone backwards
if anything they're saying that the
government's offer of eight percent over
two years would have not been enough
just on its Financial Merit but that it
also they say comes with strings
attached such as adding significant
number of hours to each trained driver's
schedule they say so therefore unions
are saying that is just not acceptable
to us and these strikes will continue
and you can see behind me Houston
Station one of the busiest in London
completely deserted on a Friday morning
on Rush Hour on the other hand the train
companies are saying well the pandemic
has left them they say in a financial
black hole they don't think the
passengers should shoulder that burden
they don't think the taxpayer should
either they say that instead they need
to be reforms and people simply don't
use the railways as they used to many
work from home Mondays and Friday so
teams of two sides are such Polar
Opposites it's really hard to see how
they can move on from this impasse
okay Malena thanks very much indeed
now the United States is tracking a
suspected Chinese surveillance balloon
over its airspace the fighter jets have
been scrambled to monitor the balloon
but it won't be shot down due to fears
of people being injured on the ground
our U.S correspondent Martha Kellner has
the latest yeah the U.S has been
watching this surveillance balloon for
the past few days before revealing
anything publicly they are now saying
that they very strongly believe that it
is a Chinese surveillance balloon and
it's over the state of Montana and
specifically the city of Billings in the
south southern part of the state you can
see pictures and videos that people have
taken on the ground quite clearly
puzzled about this strange object in the
skies above their city if you look at it
it looks almost like a small version of
the Moon and it's presented this
conundrum for the Department of Defense
and for President Biden about what he
does about it they're saying at the
moment they've decided not to shoot down
this balloon for two main reasons
firstly they're concerned they could
have heavy machinery attached to it and
if they shoot it down it may result in a
large debris field and risk to civilian
life on the ground secondly and
crucially at the moment they say they
don't believe that China is receiving
any Strategic Benefit from this balloon
then they would be getting from ordinary
satellite imagery but it is interesting
that they've chosen to situate the
balloon over the state of Montana
Montana home to one of only three U.S
military bases in the United States
which specializes in intercontinental
ballistic missiles although the
Department of Defense not saying
publicly that that's why they believe
that China have flown it there but
certainly interesting timing from the US
in publicly disclosing that they believe
there's a link to China because we're
just a few days away from a visit that
the Secretary of State Tony blinken is
taking to Beijing where he's expected to
meet with the Chinese president Xi
Jinping and certainly this episode code
is doing nothing to dilute tensions
between the two countries
cancer cases Will Rise by a third over
the next two decades taking the number
of new diagnoses each year to more than
half a million that's the warning from
cancer research UK and experts say it
should prompt a stronger push to Stamp
Out the unhealthy habits that can lead
to the disease Sky's Aisha zaheed
reports this is my best friend Amanda
in her 40s Lorraine was diagnosed with
multiple myeloma a type of blood cancer
she's been living with the illness for
nearly a decade she will live with it
for the rest of her life it's not
curable it's never curable because it's
part of my bone marrow it's part of my
blood it's it's just not something
removed and then it's been in the last
year or so that the levels have started
to go up again which means that the
treatment I was having most recently is
no longer effective like most people
regardless of what cancer you've got
cancer is so
uh sneaky shall we say that it
recognizes treatments and it and it can
just stop working so I'm now waiting to
try a different type of treatment
thousands of people will share similar
experiences and that's only expected to
increase analysis by cancer research UK
suggests that by 2040 the number of
people diagnosed with cancer Will Rise
by a third this means cases per year are
expected to increase from around 384
000 to more than half a million
particularly for those over the age of
70. the charity says that action needs
to be taken now
the less we increase Workforce and
access to Diagnostics screening and
really push early detection within the
NHS and ramp out these rapid diagnostic
Centers and improve our health of the
nation through other ways such as
restricting junk food advertising
um trying to do our best to cut smoking
rates I think the future is deeply
worrying
in response to this a government
spokesperson said we are laser focused
on fighting cancer on all fronts
prevention diagnosis treatment research
and funding so we can deliver the best
possible outcomes for patients
for Lorraine and so many others it's
essential that this commitment
materializes into better treatment and
better diagnosis Aisha zahid Sky News
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other headlines and the energy
regulator off gem has our suppliers to
suspend the forced installation of
prepayment meters and review their
processes for dealing with customers
who've fallen into arrears the request
comes after it was revealed that debt
collectors working for British gas had
forced their way into the homes of
vulnerable customers
Manchester United are to carry out their
own internal investigation into their
suspended forward Mason Greenwood the 21
year old was accused of attempted rape
controlling behavior and assault but the
charges against him were dropped
following the withdrawal of key
Witnesses in a statement Greenwood said
he's relieved
Modern Warfare is accelerating away from
the ministry of Defense due to a lack of
Technology upgrades the Public Accounts
committee says the department has been
struggling for years to deliver upgrades
and needs to act fast especially with
the war in Ukraine
apples reported its first quarterly
Revenue drop in nearly four years
blaming covert restrictions in China
which hit its factories sales during
October and December were at 96 billion
pounds down 5 on the year before supply
chain problems delayed the delivery of
iPhones during The crucial holiday
period
the Nick kyrgios has pleaded guilty in
an Australian Court to assaulting a
former girlfriend during an argument in
his hometown of Canberra in January 2021
The Wimbledon runner-up has however
avoided a criminal conviction with the
judge saying the offense was at the low
end of seriousness for a common assault
and was not premeditated
in your heads of state will hold a
summit later with Ukraine's president
zielinski among those expected to attend
are Ursula Von de Lyon the president of
the European commission and Michelle the
president of the European Council
Ukraine has applied for membership of
the EU but accession talks haven't yet
started
a report has charted an alarming 80
percent decline in the UK's butterfly
butterfly species since the 1970s
butterfly conservation a wildlife
charity says half of those remaining are
threatened or near-threatened it also
found some Southern species are
spreading North with the warming climate
now it's normally the kind of getaway
you'd see in the movies but this was
actually the scene as thieves fled
through a shopping center in Canada I
think we can see the pictures now there
we go driving a car which has been
stolen and used in a raid on an
electrical store
the thieves thought they could outwit
police by driving actually through the
shopping center which was fortunately
empty at the time the car was later
found dumped but investigations are
continuing into what police are calling
a pretty audacious crime
still to come here on the show with a
warning that yearly cancer diagnoses
could pass half a million in the coming
decades I'll be speaking to NHS
England's Clinical Director for cancer
about the work they're doing to catch
early signs of the deadly disease
neighbors Shadow immigration Minister
Stephen kinnick will be with me shortly
after eight
train strikes bringing services to a
standstill in large areas of the country
I'll speak to the chair of the rail
delivery group about what can be done to
prevent further walkouts
again
now Downing Street has said the Prime
Minister was not aware of any formal
complaints against Dominic Robb when he
was appointed as Justice secretary this
follows a report in the Times newspaper
claiming that the cabinet secretary was
personally informed of a written
complaint against Mr Robb months before
Richie sunac reappointed him
so let's bring in our political
correspondent Rob Powell very good
morning to you Rob and we know that
Dominic Robb is being investigated at
the moment amid bullying allegations so
lots of questions now about how much the
Prime Minister knew about this yeah
before we've even had this report being
compiled by Adam Tolley KC that's
expected to have a fair way to run we
are getting a slew of stories really
about how much was known by the Prime
Minister and how much was known sort of
in White Hall at the center of
government before Dominic Robb got
reappointed to the post of Justice
secretary and appointed Deputy Prime
Minister as well what the Times
newspaper is saying this morning is not
precisely that Rishi sunak knew but that
the cabinet secretary the most senior
civil servant in the government Simon
case was informed of a written complaint
months before Rishi sunak reappointed
um Dominic Raab now you would expect the
cabinet secretary to be heavily involved
in some of the propriety uh proprietary
and process that goes around some
Cabinetry appointments if there is a
kind of doubt over the propriety of it
and any doubts about the person's
Behavior now the cabinet office where
Simon case
um works these the head of essentially
is not commented on this number 10 have
said that the Justice secretary's
appointment went through the usual
process and have repeated the very
specific form of words to all
allegations of what Richard shunak knew
that he wasn't aware of any formal
complaints now of course that's crucial
because earlier this week our political
enter Beth Rigby reported a source
telling her that the Prime Minister was
told albeit informally or warned about
some aspects of Dominic Royal's behavior
before that being reappointed before
being reappointed to Justice secretary
so I think what we're starting to see
really is some of the sort of spin-off
stories land at Rishi sunak's door
before even the formal investigation is
completed of course Dominic Raab denies
accusations of bullying he said he's
confident of being cleared in this I
think for the Prime Minister he'll want
to get this report out and this matter
settled as quickly as possible yeah it's
still no clue about when it is coming
out is that no okay for the moment
thanks very much indeed Rob
now a new ski which offers households
discounts for using less electricity at
Peak periods will help avoid blackouts
it could be a blueprint for how we'll
all have to get by in the future that's
according to the National Grid which has
already activated the scheme twice this
year with temperatures falling again and
the energy crisis biting can the UK keep
the lights on this winter our climate
change correspondent Hannah Tom's Pizza
reports
this will soon be the site of a huge
onshore wind farm in the Shetland
Islands well Shetland is statistically
the windiest place in the UK Aaron
priest is building it the shift to
Renewables a chance to leave the legacy
of oil and gas behind it is the future
for Shetland and provide great
opportunities for future Generations
here but nothing in the world of energy
is perfect and at a neighboring site
already up and running we climb a
turbine to get a different view of what
is to come
earlier this year UK wind power set
records generating over half of the UK's
electricity but the problem is when the
wind stops these turbines stop producing
electricity and because we can't store
renewable energy at the scale necessary
yet something else has to fill the gap
this winter on very cold very still days
that involves people like Wendy Hall
volunteering to reduce her electricity
consumption to help avoid blackouts
everything that I can switch off without
it causing a problem to reset it then I
will do it's called the demand
flexibility service a new National Grid
scheme that pays people to use less at
peak times
I am not worried about the money it's
not about that if just switching the
power off for one hour
is a help to other people then I'm happy
to do it that's England and Wales just
down at the bottom here the scheme has
already helped the National Grid control
room balance the system but as we build
more intermittent Renewables and
Electrify our homes and vehicles it's
also the way of the future and
flexibility is going to be a really
important component of our energy Supply
mix Going forwards and it will grow and
grow as something that we all get used
to we're going to be using energy very
differently to how we use it today as
the UK contemplates the future and the
government pushes to decarbonize power
old coal-fired units are still standing
by to boost Supply if needed relics of
the Industrial Revolution a reminder of
an era that is almost over
the way we keep the lights on shifting
amid a changing world
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News
let's get more now on the warning from
cancer research UK that cancer diagnoses
will increase by a third over the next
two decades with the number of new cases
exceeding half a million a year by 2014.
well I'm joined Now by NHS England's
Clinical Director for cancer Professor
Peter Johnson a very good morning to you
thanks so much for joining us I'll come
to that warning on the number of
diagnoses in a moment but in the
meantime it's World cancer day tomorrow
first of all I was interested to get
your analysis of how the NHS is faring
as far as cancer diagnosis and treatment
goes as we Mark that day thanks very
much and very good to be with you
um the NHS is working phenomenally hard
to make sure that we see and treat
people who might have cancer as quickly
as possible and we've been seeing record
numbers of people referred in for
investigation 2.8 million over the last
year alone and also we're treating
record numbers of people 320 000 started
treatment for cancer in the last year so
we are very busy there's lots going on
uh the NHS as everybody knows is working
extremely hard because all the other
things that go on during winter
um but generally speaking I think we are
making progress we're seeing more people
than ever before and most importantly
we're catching cancer at an earlier
stage than ever before and that's thanks
to a huge amount of work across the
system and particularly raising people's
awareness of the risks of cancer which
is of course what world cancer day is
all about
would you say that the NHS is giving
treatment to the highest number of
people on record but there are more and
more cases being diagnosed with an aging
population aren't they and and that's
only going to get worse isn't it as we
said in my our introduction cancer
research is saying that the number of
people in the UK diagnosed with cancer
Will Rise by a third by 2040 in the UK
so can the NHS cope with that level of
increase
is this is very much a a feature of the
fact that we're all living longer
um and that cancer is mainly a disease
of older people so we are expecting the
numbers to go up there are of course
things we can all do to try and reduce
our own risk stopping smoking avoiding
alcohol eating healthy diet staying
active all of those things to try and
reduce the numbers of people getting
cancer will help us but nonetheless
there is there is still the fact that we
are all getting older and the NHS needs
to make sure that we've got the capacity
we've got the resources to respond to
that challenge and to make sure that
people can get the tests and the
treatments that they need
do you have the ability and the
resources now to to meet demand I mean a
record number of people in England are
waiting longer than ever for cancer
treatment aren't they How concerned are
you about that yeah there's no doubt
that there are huge pressures all the
way across the system from colleagues in
in GP surgeries through into hospitals
and we are investing very heavily into
things like the diagnostic equipment we
need the scanners the endoscopy tests
and so forth
um we're playing catch-up because we're
coming out of covid which has put a huge
strain on the system and we're trying to
get these things up and running as
quickly as we can but there's no doubt
that there are pressures and people are
waiting longer than we would want them
to wait because of that but that isn't a
reason to avoid coming forward if you've
got worrying symptoms or there's
something that isn't quite right we'd
much rather see people have them there
and know that we need to get the tests
done than to not have people coming
forward because they're in some way
worried about how the NHS can cope
well yes and tell us a little bit about
cancer survival rates because they do
lag behind that of some comparable
countries don't they what's the NHS
doing to to improve that yeah cancer
survival rates have been rising steadily
and they've gone up just about 10 over
the last decade so we are doing well but
we could always do better and there is
no doubt that catching cancer at the
earliest possible stage is the absolute
key to this and that's what we're very
focused on making sure that people know
what's right what's not right for them
so that they come and see their GP and
trying to lower the barriers to people
getting the tests trying to reduce the
time it takes to get those tests and
trying to bring in the most Innovative
treatments and the best ways of looking
after people all of that needs a huge
amount of work all of that requires a
huge amount of investment which is what
we are doing
um but there's no doubt at all that that
we can do more all the time and with
more resources and more focus on cancer
are always welcome
and you say it's important to try and
highlight early diagnosis but does it
concern you then that people are having
problems getting GP appointments
I think it's really important to
recognize how hard our colleagues in
Primary Care are working they're
referring people in record numbers we're
seeing the highest numbers of people
referred in by GPS ever as ever before
um so it's not that they're not seeing
and referring people they absolutely are
and people are coming through so if you
have got something that's not right it's
really important to to go and see your
GP surgery they are there to help they
are referring people through so although
I know that there are some pressures and
I know that it's sometimes difficult to
get an appointment straight away
nonetheless really important that people
persist and that people come forward
well Professor Peter Johnson we really
appreciate your time this morning thanks
so much for talking to us here on Sky
News thank you
on the weather now
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the mild theme will continue with
further rain in the north but Sunday
does look colder and drier overall it's
a mild start with low cloud in the north
giving outbreaks of rain Northern
Ireland will turn drier and brighter
through the morning whereas the rest of
Northern Britain will Cloud over with
some patchy rain extending eastwards
meanwhile Ireland and Southern Britain
look mainly dry
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's take a
look at the impact of climate change on
the planet and look at our little data
dashboard here well it's quite a big
data dashboard actually and just to
explain to you the right hand side of
the screen shows how the UK's power is
currently being produced so 14 from gas
for example there and then top left you
can see just how much warmer the Earth
is now than the time the industrial
revolution around 1880 that's when
modern records uh record keeping began
and then finally here bottom left you
can see the total amount of CO2
emissions in millions of tons and as you
can see that's ticking up all the time
there
now Beyonce fans hoping to buy tickets
for her UK concerts crashed a website
with huge demand for the singer's first
new tour in seven years
[Music]
[Applause]
I bet she puts on a good concert
customers reported issues during the
purchasing process after pre-sale
tickets went live for O2 customers only
but all is not lost as fans will have
access to other pre-sale events today
followed by a general sale on Tuesday
the 7th of February
now do say with us here on Sky News
breakfast as a new report uncovers
terrible conditions at a women's prison
in gloucestershire I'll be speaking to
the Chief Inspector of Prisons about
what improvements are needed
[Music]
hello welcome back now conditions at a
prison holding women with mental health
problems have been described as
appalling by a watchdog some sales at
Eastwood Park in gloucestershire were
found smeared with scratches and blood
stains the Chief Inspector of Prisons
said an experienced member of his staff
said they were the worst he'd ever seen
and Charlie Taylor joins me now welcome
to you thanks so much for coming in to
talk to us about this
um tell us a little bit more about your
findings at this prison well Eastwood
Park is holds about 350 women in
gloucestershire and this is one of the
most concerning inspections that I've
done we very rarely give out our lowest
score for safety for women's prisons
which tend to be safer places but in
this case we were really concerned
particularly on one house block where
the conditions that women were being
held in were appalling they were in dark
dingy cells that they was scratch marks
on the walls they hadn't been cleaned
properly there was graffiti everywhere
and the women in there we're in extreme
mental distress so these were women who
were very unwell some of them were
self-harming in in The Most Extreme Ways
and we were very concerned that the
prison simply wasn't doing enough to
look after those women let me just um
show you which you will have seen of
course the ministry of show our viewers
the ministry of Justice response to this
and a spokesperson has said I think we
can show it in our screen and this is a
deeply concerning report and we are
already addressing the serious issues it
raises including appointing more staff
and creating a new task force to improve
women's safety at the prison and given
what you've seen are you reassured At
All by the response from the ministry
well one of one of the challenges that
they faced at Eastwood Park is they
didn't have enough staff so it's good if
more staff are going in there that's
excellent but the other thing that that
we felt very strongly was the level of
training for staff these were some very
young staff members we're dealing with
some women in acute distress and they
said simply didn't have the skill set
they weren't being looked after in a way
that was gonna mean they could give
these women what they needed and quite
honestly some of the women we saw there
shouldn't have been in prison at all
they should have been in hospital
whether that was Secure hospital or a
community hospital but they simply
wasn't appropriate to hold those women
in prison how common are conditions like
this
for women's prisons generally what we
find in women's prisons is conditions
are usually better so this is very
unusual to find things as bad as they
were at Eastwood Park however we very
often find women who ought to be in
hospital being locked up in prison and
that's a big concern for us so how would
you describe the levels of stress that
women in that prison were experiencing
well on that particular Wing these were
people who were very unwell anyway but
they were very unwell people who are
being kept in conditions that simply
were not going to make them better and
we're going to exacerbate the problems
that were already there and you talk
about not enough staff and not enough
training as well I mean how much of an
issue is that more broadly in in
recruitment but also the right kind of
training well that's right I mean
recruitment has been a problem retention
has been a problem within the prison
service but also what really worried me
in Eastwood park is there were some very
young very dedicated very impressive
staff but they simply didn't have the
capabilities to deal with the women who
were in their care they didn't have the
Healthcare Training they weren't getting
the mental health support and therefore
they were being put in an impossible
situation and I was worried about the
staff's mental health as well as the
mental health of the prisoners so what
would you like to see happen now well
we'd like to see some improvements to
that house block very quickly we'd like
to see a focus on training of staff so
that they understand and are able to
deal with people with those difficulties
but most important of all we'd like to
see enough beds in in hospitals and an
end to some of the bureaucratic
processes that stop people who should be
in hospital from languishing in prison
do you feel that some steps are being
taken I read here that a dedicated
safety task force group is being
established that some maintenance work
for example the surroundings are being
improved as well as additional staff as
we mentioned being taken on newly
designed care plans that there seems to
be some some steps in place well look
that's all good news we'll wait and see
till we go back to the prison whether
that's had the effect that we would like
it to have okay so so you think that in
itself may not be enough well let's wait
and see what happens when we go back to
the jail it's good that something's
being done but but we want to see the
impact on the women who are in the jail
and on the staff who are there and how
soon do you go back how often do you
carry out we'll be back at Eastwood park
within the next year
within the next year so so at what stage
is that likely to have at some stage in
the next year so so probably
um sometime towards the end of the
summer into the Autumn okay so you'd
like to see improvements by then well
Charlie Taylor thanks very much indeed
for your time thank you for coming in to
talk to us about it affected by the
scandals so gentlemen thanks both so
much for coming in to tell us about your
experiences and Richard I want to hear
about your story in a moment but first
there's to you first of all as a kind of
overview today will be the end of a
series of hearings over a number of
years into the infected blood Scandal
what do you make of the proceedings and
what you've heard it's been four years
it's four years of evidence it's four
years of hearing people give evidence
and reading papers behind the evidence
which they've given
it's been a very very painful time for
the victims because every time they give
evidence or every time they hear the
story again and again and again they
have to relive it so it's been very
important for the victims insofar as
what the inquiry will uncover we don't
know yet because of course the report is
unlikely to appear before us until
sometime later this year we're told but
doing the best you we can we do believe
that it has been beneficial it's been a
process of catharsis if you'd like so
that people can begin to understand why
whatever happened did happen one of the
disappointing things about it I have to
say is that the Department of Health
began this inquiry and very very openly
saying we are sorry that was foreign
over four years ago when asked about 10
days ago
could it tell us what they were sorry
about
they didn't they couldn't they refused
and we had hoped that this inquiry would
uncover the truth and there would be an
openness about what happened an openness
about what happened why it happened and
why it should not have happened and all
we get at the moment in the closing days
of the inquiry is the Department of
Health a Secretary of State for health
refusing to give proper instructions to
his lawyers so those lawyers can appear
before the inquiry and say what they
apologize for now that is serious and
once that the report is published what
do you want from the government what we
want from the government is a full and
detailed apology not a meaningless
paragraph in a document which appears
before the inquiry we want someone from
the Department of Health and the
government but it is part of the
government to say what they did what
they did that and accept that what they
did was wrong and that they will do the
utmost to make sure that this never
happens again now as long as they are in
denial and they're still in denial
believe you me that will not happen and
it's important that it does okay and and
Richard I I want to hear your story tell
us what happened to you okay well I'm a
severe hemophiliac and was infected with
two forms of hepatitis and HIV as a
child
um and how did that infection happen
um so treatment factor eight treatment
that was given to me by the NHS
and how's that affected your life
in every way possible it's prevented us
from having children
being able to hold down meaningful
employment
um this the amount of stigma the level
of stigma that goes along with it's
being Dreadful
um explain that to me why is this
um well Dolores I think there always has
been and always will be and people I
think are naturally frightened of you
know of being around people that are
known to have these these these viruses
and I think it's just a natural thing
but it is still about today as it as
prevalent as it was I believe in the
1980s
um I believe the the fear is tangible
it's still there and we actually moved
to when we first got married we actually
moved to Native the country but it was
affect essentially rural so that we
could be away from from the public and
it's it's still something that plays in
our minds I think every day
um it's it's a huge impact on your huge
huge impact on our lives and it's it's
ongoing
um I've been campaigning for 30 plus
years the culmination of which has been
this public inquiry which has been four
and a half years of it
but I don't know what I and I think this
applies to many many other people that
have been rigorously campaigning as well
I don't really know what we're going to
do after this inquiry finishes uh we're
going to be left with this this void
um because we have put so much into it
we've dedicated Our Lives to campaigning
for you know for for people infected
unaffected people and and we've lost so
many along the way and what will make it
worth it that campaigning and that drive
for this inquiry what kind of result do
you feel you need to see first of all
first and foremost I think we need a
wholesome and full meaningful apology
from government not something that's
whispered over the dispatch box
um I don't think there can ever be
closure the only way in which government
can
recompense is is perhaps the best word
uh victims and their families is
financially that's the only way they can
possibly do it they can never give us
back our health there isn't a Magic
Bullet that will reverse the hepatitis C
and HIV infections
um I don't think we'll ever be closure
but it's so late in the day that this
inquiry should have happened 30 years
ago and people are people are old people
are tired
um and I just hope to God that the
government gets their finger out and
acts swiftly
um and lets people lets people get on
with the the lives that they have left
as time is running out
you gave evidence yourself and you're
one of the hearings how was that
I wasn't going to do it at the beginning
I was going to be anonymous
but at the very last minute I said to my
wife let's do this we can do this
and it's to be honest it was the most
cathartic thing I think I've ever done
because I've lived with a shadow over my
head for for years and years and years
and tried to
keep everything under my hat and the
same went for both of us
um didn't talk about it much but as soon
as that hearing had finished as soon as
I gave my oil evidence it felt like this
huge wage had been lifted off my
shoulders suddenly I felt free we both
felt free
um we've heard some tragic tragic
stories of the inquiry
um but it's been a remarkable inquiry I
don't think we could have wished for
from our
um yeah
and does when you hear stories like
Richards to be talking about financial
compensations feels fairly poultry
doesn't it really and yet the government
has stepped up that there is money
promised isn't there
um
the government's agreed to pay thousands
of eligible victims a 100 000 pound
interim payment yeah are you satisfied
with the levels of compensation for your
clients the present levels of
compensation or what they will be are
unknown the the thousand pounds uh
interim payment we've never been told
what it's interim to so normally someone
says well this is what you get now
you're getting something else later the
government's been totally silent about
what it's interim to so what's going to
happen in the future the interim
payments have only been made to a very
very narrow group of people a huge
number have received nothing and
um you be forgiven for thinking
basically that that was the government
trying to get off the hook last August
September October there was a
recommendation from the inquiry that
those payments be made it did it did
comply with that recommendation but
since then it's been struggling at the
end of a hook trying to get off and
so far successfully we're hopeful that
that will not carry on and that the
compensation will be paid at some point
in the very very near future okay okay
well we're out of time now but perhaps
you'll come back when the report comes
out but there's Collins and Richard
Warwick thank you both very much thank
you for coming in and for sharing your
story thank you very much thank you
now in the last few minutes China's
Foreign Affairs Ministry has responded
to the United States which says that
it's tracking a suspected Chinese
surveillance balloon over its airspace
and speaking earlier this hour China's
foreign Ministry spokesperson Mao ning
has said they're trying to establish the
facts
China is a responsible country and we
act in accordance with international law
we have no intention to violate other
countries sovereignty and airspace and
as I said we are gathering and verifying
the facts we hope relevant parties would
hand I would handle the matter in a good
headed way
and of course we bring all the latest on
that throughout the morning time now
about for a look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the mild theme will continue with
further rain in the north but Sunday
looks colder and drier overall it's a
mild start with low cloud in the north
giving outbreaks of rain Northern
Ireland will turn drier and brighter
through the morning whereas the rest of
Northern Britain will Cloud over with
patchy rain extending eastwards
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
now then after years of wrangling what's
known as the Stonehenge of the north
will today be handed over to the nation
it consists of a series of massive
Earthworks at thornbra in North
Yorkshire known as henges believed to be
up to 5 000 years old and they've been
threatened by quarrying but now they're
being handed over to Historic England
and English Heritage who describe them
as the most important Neolithic
monuments in the north of England